it is like a raw squid
hi it's Ria and I'm Twain
so it's so exciting to have her today
she's going to be a new hot stop making
big I'm kind of nervous for that but
it's really really exciting yeah today
we are not making anything big okay but
we are swapping snacks I picked my
favorite Japanese snacks okay I'm
excited for that I have some really good
Vietnamese snacks for you let's bring
the first one in yeah one two three
oh all right so mine is called have you
seen this no I've never seen that this
is my favorite since when I was high
school this is actually made with potato
salad
yeah wow so if you use that you're gonna
say so this is a potato snack that's
made out of potatoes
so if you soak in hot water this becomes
potatoes wow okay that's cool so this is
my snack I don't know what it's called
because I can't read this but I call it
rice rolls okay and this one is my
favorite flavor it's the egg yolk flavor
this was always in the pantry I never
cared for it because this doesn't look
appetizing to me there's like beans yeah
look very healthy yes it just looks so
healthy but one day I just needed a
quick snack and I was like okay fine
I'll finally give this a try and I
finished all of it oh my God in one
sitting because it's just like so
addictive oh wow yeah let's swap here
you go looks like a seasoned fry yeah
I like this a lot yeah it's a nice mouth
feel
um
I definitely could finish this in like
10 minutes I don't think I've had
anything similar snack wise to this but
maybe like a stale McDonald's fry
flavor is still fried yes crunchy but
crunchy right please try mine yes I've
never introduced anybody to this this
has been like my little secret oh wow
hmm
it melts in your mouth Yes I think it's
addictive because it doesn't have a very
strong flavor I'm so happy you like it
do you have to decide yes I will keep
mine I think I will also keep mine it's
so difficult to give up your own
favorite snack right yeah that was fun
but we have more snacks to swap yeah I'm
excited ready yeah three two one all
right
oh you're so excited yes so this is
called bun Pia and this is my favorite
flavor I'm not sure if you've ever tried
durian before
okay
but this is durian flavor okay with a
cured egg yolk inside okay I've never
had a junior itself okay but I had a
dream moon cake before and it was good I
don't know who this is according to but
I guess it's like the stinkiest fruit in
the world but to me like it was always
super fragrant I really like to snack
after the gym especially like sweet
snacks so yeah after the gym snack for
the gains okay so mine eat I have seen
these before yeah but I've never tried
it this is just a reverse engineer or
Pokey you know everyone knows yeah Pokey
is a pretzel stick covered with
chocolate but sometimes they get melty
especially hot outside you stick in a
package but top ball very smart it's
chocolate it's inside I love that yeah
okay here you guys do it
it's very creamy it's like a lot of
flavor come in a different timing like
first I tasted something very creamy and
then like pandans kind of refreshing
pandan smell came and then like after
taste it's like durian yeah so
everything kind of unfolds yeah all
right I want to try yours now
foreign
I didn't expect there to be that much
chocolate in a bite I like that it's not
too sweet that's like Asian sweets
that's a compliment
when they eat sweet stuff and that's the
best compliment yeah not too sweet not
too sweet since I keep eating this I'm
gonna keep this yeah okay
no literally I just keep eating it okay
I'm gonna choose this
WOW but I feel like this is a little bit
boring three two one full disclosure
this is not Japanese dessert okay but
Japan has Trend every year and this was
became very popular it's called the
natade cocoa oh it's Filipino dessert
yeah have you had this kind of
experience when you had something so
delicious but you have no idea what it
is and you're kind of like in a outer
space and like you kind of whoa
I'm pretty sure you've had this before
but this is um okay well this is just
soy milk okay so this soy milk is my
childhood I would have this at school
all the time this is what they would
serve at school whenever I hear people
say that they don't like soy milk I
automatically know that they have not
had Asian soy milk because American soy
milk versus Asian soy milk is completely
different but this is the way to go all
right
oh it's Greek yogurt
foreign
squid
if you could bite into a jellyfish yes
that would be the texture of a jellyfish
I like the pandan though yeah yeah this
is my life changing dessert
I did not have an out-of-body experience
now I'm gonna try yours okay
they're all as cool as a paper straw
dots
this is the soy milk I'm familiar with
right it's so good it's more creamy and
it's a little bit sweeter okay I have to
admit something I don't like the yogurt
I would have to swap and have the soy
milk over here bye I'm gonna smoke I
want natta de cocoa all right last one
last one
yes I am so excited for you to try so
this is beard Papa okay cream puff
interesting name yes the shoe is very
crisp because they stuff cream when you
order and I like tea so whenever I have
time like I want to make myself a cup of
tea and like have something sweet and
this is perfect and it's like perfect
size yeah so here is a moon cake and
this is my favorite filling in Mooncake
is the mixed nuts this time there's two
yolks in here
this is very common in Vietnam around
this time of the years the mid-autumn
festival we celebrate that and this is
my favorite moon cake there's a lot of
different types of moon cakes and
different types of filling but this is
my favorite like all time red swap here
you go
that's Ginger it has everything
reminds me of my like childhood when I
had a snack up my grandparents house
yeah it's a bit of a Savory yeah that's
what I love about it that's what I love
about the egg yolk the outer layer is
like sweet the mixed nuts it's a little
bit sweet it's not too much it's an
interesting very interesting flavors and
textures right I really want to dig into
this yeah should I just like you can or
should I just bite into it you just bite
into it this is so good yay there's also
like little specks of like vanilla in
here too vanilla beans yeah yeah I
really love the out
yeah yeah can I have it too
yes oh my God this is It's just so
perfect yeah not too sweet so you can
eat like the full thing without feeling
like I just ate the full thing
reminds me of my childhood I'm Gonna
Keep mine I'm actually gonna oh swap to
hers this is really good yeah thank you
so much for watching and thank you so
much for joining me today yeah well
thank you for having me and make sure to
tune in on the next season of making it
big maybe she's gonna make cream puff
giant puff oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]